welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and with the new she-hulk series
bringing abomination back to the
forefront of the mcu people everywhere
that didn't live in harlem in 2008 are
finally excited to see marvel studios
bring back one of the first villains of
the mcu this video is brought to you by
squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building your brand more on them later
but if abomination is the mcu's second
ever villain what about their third
villain and no i'm not talking about the
russian guy with the bird i want my butt
i'm talking about the sketchy guy who's
a nerd with a forehead that's absurd the
leader whatever happened to that guy
anyway the mcu like set him up and then
nothing we never saw him again so like
what happened to the leader and why do i
have this strange feeling that we're
going to see him appear in the she-hulk
series well let's see if we can't follow
the leader together my nerd babies
[Applause]
but first be sure to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can buy all
of our amazing nerd inspired merch i'm
including our new four love and thunder
inspired latest obsession shirts which
are not gonna stay around forever so you
can buy that shirt and all of our
amazing merch options over at new
rockstars.com because we got stickers we
got hats we got all sorts of fun stuff
so head on over to there today alright
so the reason why i believe the leader
is going to show up in she-hulk is
mainly because of how she-hulk gets her
powers in the mcu from recent promo
material it seems like mcu jennifer
walters will gain her green gamma gal
powers from a car accident that both her
and her cousin bruce get into and
because bruce is still getting over his
infinity war wound on his arm during the
time of the accident a good amount of
hulk blood finds its way into jennifer's
own open wounds giving her enough of
bruce's gamma irradiated blood cells to
hulk out a little bit like how hulk's
blood led to the rather gross gamma
transformation of samuel stern's head
into that of a highway billboard because
my god that [ __ ] was huge just a little
bit of bruce's blood was enough to
mutate sternz's brain to a crazy degree
to the point where he can now remember
absolutely everything that his brain
processes you know much like the leader
can do in the comics and not only that
but this dude is even so smart that he
can predict the freaking future with
near-perfect accuracy just based on the
data he's given like that's freaking
nuts like i know that reed richards is
the supposed smartest man alive but i'm
not too sure about that because if the
leader is anything like he is in the
comics like there are almost no limits
to how much this dude can learn which is
why the leader is one of the most
notorious villains within the incredible
hulk's rogues gallery in the comics my
man does not have a six head for nothing
jesus this dude is quite literally one
of the smartest people in the marvel
comics universe and he frequently uses
that sinister sixth head of his for evil
against his brute of an arch enemy the
incredible hulk and in the mcu he is the
person pretty much directly responsible
for emil blonsky becoming the
abomination in the first place because
if we turn back the clock to the year
2008 when i was getting rejected by
girls in high school samuel stearns was
getting a gun pointed to his face by a
crazy british guy who apparently can't
get it up unless he can 1v1 the hulk irl
without being thrown into a tree is that
where you go
and boy let me tell you that samuel
stearns was quick to oblige because uh
that dude was a nut job who loves
science a little bit too much mostly
because as stearns puts it
look
i've always been more curious than
cautious now guys you only get one
chance to make a first impression right
if you're starting an online business
your first impression has to not only
look good it's got to be functional and
that's where squarespace comes in
squarespace is an all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence for
that new business you want your website
to tell everyone that you know what
you're doing loud and clear and
squarespace does just that squarespace
has a bunch of great features to help
your business be successful you can
present members only gated content
create email campaigns or add online
booking for appointments or sessions all
from the squarespace interface for me my
favorite aspect is the analytics section
that's where squarespace makes it easy
to dig into what's working what's not
and figure out what levers you can pull
to make your business even more
successful so head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 percent off your
first purchase of a website or domain
that's squarespace.com new rockstars for
10 off your first purchase of a website
or domain like stearns was all about
that science nerd life man like to a
supremely dangerous and detrimental
degree this dude was not phased in the
least while watching both bruce and
blonsky transform into their huge forms
for the first time because samuel
stearns was obsessed with the idea of
gamma radiation being the key to solving
all of humanity's future problems so
much so that while bruce banner thought
he could trust samuel stearns with a
sample of his blood so that stearns
could help cure bruce's disease turns
out that little maniac decided to
replicate the little blood that he got
enough to fill an entire room with a
bunch of hemoglobin hulk juice and one
of the biggest reasons why i believe
that we are going to see stearns pop up
in she-hulk is because of this room in
particular after the events of 2008's
incredible hulk movie we have no idea
where any of these samples of hulk
making blood are at and it's been like
17 mcu years since we've seen that hulk
blood last but seeing as she-hulk is
gearing up to introduce a bunch of
mysteriously powered people like titania
in the mix i can see this blood being
spread around the mcu by the sketchy and
nefarious forces of the mc forces like
hydra who we already know is massively
interested in developing a super-powered
army of their own for world domination
from their interest in darren cross's
yellowjacket army in ant-man one and
were also coincidentally the very group
who had direct access to samuel stern's
intellectual mind because according to
issues 7 and 8 of the mcu cannon right
after samuel stern's brain mutated on
the floor of his laboratory he was
confronted by none other than natasha
romanov herself who immediately shot
that crazy nerd in the kneecaps after
the leaders started rambling about how
he could see an illustrious future
defined by power and influence and tried
to get natasha to help him grab all of
his research so that they could enjoy
the future that the leader foresaw
together like he literally tried to get
natasha to switch sides to be like yo
i'm smart now i can see the future
come with me girl because i i could i
swear i gots like
and then after swearing vengeance on
natasha for shooting him the leader is
then taken in by shield and locked up in
a liquid containment tube never seen
again since like she's just been in that
tube for
20 years
however since shield was actually hydra
as it was revealed in captain america
winter soldier i'm sure you can begin to
see how this could begin to be a problem
for the mcu because if shield was in
fact the entity that picked up stearns
and all of the hulk's blood samples then
hydra could potentially have both of
those elements as well and if stearns
has this really intricate and thought
out vision of a future defined by power
and influence that kind of sounds like a
captain america new world order to me
and ruling the world with power and
influence is literally hydra's entire
jam and since we already know that val
is walking around the mcu telling crazy
jonathan's that the future is about to
get weird and that it's not going to
need a captain america or you know the
avengers i'm of the mind to think that
val could be working with the leader to
try to gain power and influence likely
through a group of smart superpowered
villains the leader is very much
affiliated with in the comics the
intelligentsia who are already mcu canon
as of avengers 2 when we learn that
ulysses claw is a known affiliate of
this mysterious group of misbehaving
madmen but this all being said because
she-hulk is all about how a woman who
came in contact with bruce's blood
navigates a world with a rapidly growing
number of superhuman people coming out
of seemingly nowhere we could very much
end up seeing she-hulk teaming up with
daredevil to try to find out where all
of these new super criminals are even
coming from and i think that there's a
good chance it's going to lead us to a
bottle factory of bruce's blood with the
leader experimenting on humankind to
fulfill his future but that is why i
believe the leader will show up in
she-hulk because i just believe that
this show is going to set up a lot of
themes that are sort of matching the
like threads that were left in the end
of the incredible hulk 2008 but what do
you guys think do you guys think that we
are going to see the nerdy samuel
stearns in she-hulk let us know in the
comment section below mine are babies so
you can follow me at mestertainment on
twitter if you guys want to see me tweet
some really weird [ __ ] thank you guys so
much for watching i love you guys so
much and i appreciate your time and i'll
see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you